well the Senate had its procedural votes
today to end debate on on Kavanagh s
confirmation which sets up the final
confirmation vote for tomorrow and in a
normal situation that would be you know
that would be a you'd have pretty good
certainty that he'll be confirmed
because they move forward but it was 51
to 49 in favor but you never know you
never know if somebody will switch now
from a yes to a no in between now and
then nothing is certain and I'm sure the
Democrats will try to pull another
rabbit out of the Hat in the next 24
hours we'll see if they pull it off but
as we hopefully move now towards
Cavanaugh's confirmation I have just a
couple things I want to say and I'll
start with this
after Kavanagh is confirmed if he's
confirmed I think there should be
another FBI investigation and that's
what the Democrats want right they're
not they weren't satisfied with the with
the investigation that was that was done
because it turned up nothing it turned
up nothing on Cavanaugh anyway and so
they weren't satisfied with that they
want to do another FBI investigation
which which which of course is a
shocking turn of events right I mean
we're all just completely shocked that
the Democrats were unsatisfied with the
FBI investigation that they demanded but
anyway I actually agree with them that
there should be another FBI
investigation but not into Cavanaugh
that's been done there should be an FBI
investigation into Christine Ford and
her attorneys and Senate Democrats now
the mass media is not not going to
report this news of course but this is
really blockbuster stuff okay I don't
know if you saw this
Monica McClain who is the former FBI
agent and friend of Christine Ford the
the the first time we heard her name was
a few days ago when Ford's ex-boyfriend
came out and said and said under oath he
said that Ford helped to coach McLane on
how to pass a lie-detector test I guess
when she was originally interviewing to
work for the FBI and that
significant because it means that it
means number one that Ford lied under
oath and it also means that Ford knows
how to pass lie-detector stat
lie-detector test she knows how to beat
him right and which would call her
polygraph examination into in a question
well now according to Ford's high school
friend he got to kind of follow the
threads here I know it gets confusing
but according to Ford's high school
friend Leland Kaiser MacLean called her
Kaiser to pressure her to change her
story remember Leland kaisers is is the
one who was supposed to be a witness for
Ford she was supposedly at this party
where this thing supposedly happened but
kaisers been saying the whole time I
have no memory of any party I didn't
know I didn't know brick have enough
right well according to her this F this
former FBI agent and friend of Christine
Ford called her to try to pressure her
to I think the word she used was revisit
her her testimony and then it was after
that now you remember may remember a few
days ago the media made a big deal of it
when Kaiser came out and said I still
don't remember anything from this party
and I don't know Brett Kavanaugh but I
believe Christine Ford
that was the first time she had said it
was first time she said she believed her
and apparently was after she had been
getting getting pressure from this
former FBI agent it's a very interesting
on a number of levels this is very
interesting because obviously it
indicates a potential cover-up it also
reveals that MacLaine is not just some
random person when Ford's ex-boyfriend
first mentioned her we thought she was
just some random friend we didn't think
there was any significance to the name
but but now we find out that she's
deeply involved in all this and also
when MacLean denied what the
ex-boyfriend said I think now that
denial is suspect because of how deeply
involved she is okay so package that
with chuck grassley letter to Ford's
attorneys last night where he makes
mention very cryptically of a certain
communications between Democrats and
Ford and between Ford and the other
Cavanaugh accusers in fact let me
let me see if I can pull that up I'm not
sure if I still have it all right so
chuck grassley sent a letter to forged
attorneys last night asking yet again
for whatever evidence Ford supposedly
has asking her to turn it over
especially the therapists notes now let
me read the last pair of Airy
interesting last paragraph of this
letter he says I urge you once again now
for the third time in writing to turn
over the therapy notes polygraph
materials and communications with the
Washington Post that dr. Ford has relied
upon as evidence in addition to the
evidence I requested in my October 2nd
letter in light in light of recently
uncovered information please turn over
records and descriptions of direct or
indirect communications between dr. Ford
or her representatives and any of the
following one u.s. senators or their
staffs particularly the offices of
senators Feinstein in her ona Hirono
other than your communication with me
and my staff in preparation for the
September set 27th hearing to the
alleged witnesses identified by dr. Ford
Leland Kaiser mark judge and Patricia
and a Patrick Smith and three
Debbie Ramirez Julie sweat Nick or their
representatives wow that's that's pretty
significant this is the first time we've
heard anything about four potentially
Ford communicating with sweat Nick and
and Ramirez this is starting to look
more and more like a coordinated
political hit job and if that's what
this is then this is one of the worst
scandals in American political history
by far and it certainly warrants an
investigation we need to know now now we
need to know how did all this come about
what's going on behind the scenes
because because this cannot be allowed
again it's not only destructive of an
innocent man and his family but it
erodes our very system of government so
anyone involved or potentially involved
with a conspiracy like this has to be
punished severely so there has to be an
investigation if there was any I mean
there could be multiple I have no ideas
if I have no idea if there was
coordination I don't know if there was
coordination I don't know what it
consisted of but there could be multiple
ways of coordination here and if there
was any coordination at all at all
between Ford and Democrats or Ford and
the other accusers if they coordinated
to any extent whatsoever then that's a
huge scandal and I think that this
warrants a federal investigation because
you just can't you can't have that I
mean there can't be any whiff there
can't be the slightest whiff of
coordination with something like this
Ford needs to have been completely
independent coming out completely on her
own of her own accord to tell a story
that is completely her own if if any
part of that is not true right if this
if this story wasn't completely hers
because someone helped her craft it or
if it wasn't completely her decision to
come forward because she was pressured
into it by Democrats or say anything
like that it's a huge scandal so yeah I
think there should be an FBI
investigation second thing I want to
mention I've been thinking about this
with the with the Kavanagh and the you
have this incredible hostility towards
men that has been brought to the surface
on the part of leftist especially
feminists and this is not a revelation
obviously we know that feminists hate
men but it's always remarkable when you
see it displayed and you see really the
hatred of men and that's what's been
bubbling over in these last few weeks
this hatred of men which is delusional
along with an equally delusional victim
mentality so we've seen the victim
mentality of left-wing feminists over
this Cavanagh thing so take the kind of
the anti Cavanagh demonstrations
yesterday Elizabeth Warren showed up at
one of them and before we get to that so
you got these these are demonstrations
and you look at the signs and what these
muds mostly women you look at what
they're shouting and the signs okay
they're saying we don't want to be Sylar
we're not gonna be silenced and they I
saw several of them holding signs that
said the sign said something like we're
fighting for our lives or this is a
fight for our lives really this is a
fight for your life your life is in
jeopardy who's threatening your life I
know people have been threatening
Cavanaugh's life and and Senate
Republicans and his family I know people
but but your your life is who has
threatened your life how was how was
this a fight for your life I was but
then Elizabeth Elizabeth Warren showed
up and she declared that women this is
what she said she says women are tired
quote tired of being told to sit down
and shut up
what this is this is easily the dumbest
of all the dumb feminists talking points
this idea that women are being silenced
and told to shut up you hear that all
the time
Kamala Harris this is her favorite thing
to say I won't be silenced women will no
longer be what do you talk a sight where
is that happening well you're not you're
not being silenced what are you talking
about
where are these men who are supposedly
going around telling women to sit down
and shut up and be silent where are
women in America being silenced I don't
see it happening
I mean can you give me one example I've
never I have never in my life ever heard
a man say that all women need to sit
down and shut up and not chime in on
whatever a particular subject now I hear
women I hear feminist women say that
about men all the time all the times one
of their favorite things to say they're
constantly telling us that we're not
allowed to participate in certain
discussions and pretty much any
discussion if we're white man is white
men we're not allowed to be a part of
any discussion um and so they're always
telling us that we're always being told
to sit down in fact senator Hirono she
said those words exactly
she said men need to shut up so yeah
we're being told to shut up but but
where are it can you get I mean can you
give me like two or three examine can
you even give me one example of a
prominent man coming out and said you
know women you really need to shut up
about this what
I mean it's I can't even say it so it
makes me laugh because no one no one
says that
so just so-so you're being silly really
is way this is just this is total
silliness you're being hysterical I know
feminists hate it when when they're
called hysterical but you're being
absolutely hysterical and you need to
calm down because nobody is telling you
to be silent no one is silencing you no
one is telling you to shut up at all
from my vantage point and I don't say
this disparagingly I don't say it as a
complaint but from my vantage point it
seems like women do quite a bit of
talking and so silenced women it doesn't
seem like I mean it just it seems to me
what just living in society it seems
like women are not shy about talking and
making their opinion known hi so I a
part of this is and this is kind of a
side the point but you hear feminists
complain all the time about about men
talking over them and interrupting and
so forth and this is just another
example of the incredible narcissism of
feminists where they think that
everything's about them they think
everything that happens to them is it's
they're the only ones that it happens to
so they'll tell these sob stories of you
know one time I was at a meeting and a
male coworker interrupted me and he D
legitimized my point of view and he
authorized me it was so terrible
Oates that's that's just a that's a
human experience okay get over yourself
it happens to everybody it's part of
human communication people get
interrupted they get talked over you
think that never happens to us you know
that we you think we never get
interrupted or talked over but a
feminist is interrupted or disagreed
with in that actually that's what they
mean when they say they're being
silenced what they really mean is they
are being disagreed with so they say a
Brett Kavanaugh is a rapist and then if
you say well I disagree with that stop
silencing me you're silencing me excuse
me and I really disagree with your point
here your sight
stop silencing me I will not be silenced
good lord grow up get over
learn to deal with life learn to deal
with existing as a in a human society
nobody's silencing you you have never
been silenced all you do is scream and
complain silenced you're shouting into a
freaking megaphone I mean that's what
feminism has become right it's become a
bunch of women on a street corner
screaming into a megaphone that they're
being silenced that's what it is they're
like screaming into your ear I'm being
silenced it's like no you're not I mean
can you you're not being sounds at all
effect you're gonna you're gonna blow my
eardrums out what you're gonna do s'okay
I mean can you at least turn down the
volume slightly the funny thing is that
normal women
that is to say non feminist women
healthy women their biggest complaint
about men is usually the opposite right
women are constantly trying to get men
to talk if my wife has always said you
know what are you thinking about that's
that's the classic woman question men
never ask that question that's a woman
is it wants you to talks like talk some
more you're not talking enough that's
how it goes in reality that so I've
never in my life actually I don't I
don't think I can't think of a time in
my life when I've been in like a mixed
group with men and women and all the men
are talking while the women remain
silent you know I I don't think I've
ever seen that I've seen the opposite
I've seen the opposite happened quite a
bit but I've never seen that but these
feminists they paint this picture of his
penis picture of society where men are
talking and engaging in lively
discussion while all the women are
sitting quietly and meekly in a corner
you know afraid to say anything they
can't speak it's laughable
that never happens never what world it
what country are you living in you're
not living in your night
maybe maybe Saudi Arabia you're not
living in the United States women are
definitely definitely definitely not
silenced by men I mean women
I think statistically women say five
times more in a day that a man does
they definitely use women use a lot more
words in a day than men do so how could
we even if we wanted to silence women we
can't keep up how could we anyway the
point here is that is that the root of a
lot of this Cavanaugh stuff is a is a
hatred of men and it's a hatred of men
that is delusional as I said and not
based in reality and and not based in
any kind of actual understanding of how
men are and how they operate which again
you know women who are not feminists
because they're they're healthy and
normal you know they have husbands and
everything and they've got and they've
been around man they understand men more
so they're not going this ridiculous
cartoonish caricature of of manhood that
you get from feminists well women who
have actually been around men and been
married to a man and all that kind of
stuff they know how silly it is so
that's not that's just not that's not
how men operate right men have flaws but
no that's not it so that's what comes
through loud and clear when you when you
when you listen to leftists on this just
take us as one example among many there
was a in The New Yorker in The New
Yorker this this morning there was a
headline the headline was at the Senate
Judiciary Committee hearing Brett
Kavanaugh seemingly weaponized crying
the way a little boy does when he's in
trouble so they they you see just
contempt for men can you imagine can you
imagine that same headline but about
Christine Ford can you imagine a
headline can you imagine if somebody
wrote something that said Christine Ford
weaponised crying the way a little girl
does when she's in trouble can you
imagine if somebody wrote a headline
calling Christine Ford a little girl and
mocking her for crying the feminists
would explode in
in an outrage that would reach atomic
proportions okay there be there would
actually be ready
there would be radioactive fallout we
would all get radiation poisoning from
there outrage that's how intense
white-hot it would be if if anyone dared
say anything even approaching that about
any woman especially Christine Ford but
this is what this is what they do they
what they what the left does is they
immediately convict Cavanaugh and then
they convict all men by extension so
this becomes a problem of men a white
men specifically which is even more
absurd where we hear over and over again
so this is a bunch of white man's a
white man white what does white have to
do I mean the fact that he's a man has
nothing to do with it but the fact that
he's white what does this skin color
what do we keep hearing about he's a
white man so are you suggesting that
what sexual assault is more common among
white men because let me tell you
something you better come with some
statistics if that's your suggestion if
you're trying to imply that there's
somehow some correlation between white
men and sexual assault you better come
with some a citation is gonna be needed
on that one because I don't think that's
true I just leave it at that I don't I
don't think that's true and in fact
there are countries in the world where
it's essentially legal for men to rape
women but those are not white countries
I'll just tell you that those are not
countries dominated by white people so
the white thing is nothing to do with it
and the fact that he's a man has nothing
to do with it either but liberals will
take any opportunity they can to beat up
on their favorite punching bag and then
you ask the question why you know what
why do feminists have such contempt for
men and that they're so gleeful about
they love any opportunity to to vomit
that that hatred on men and I've said
this theory before but my theory is that
for feminists their hatred of men if I
if I was really too psyched
psychoanalyze them I think their hatred
comes down to envy
feminists hate men because they want to
be men so they're jealous of all the
masculine traits which they lack but
they covet and so when they see those
traits in a man they feel resentful in
essence feminists want to tear down men
get rid of men so that they can take the
place of men thus you have this very
weird situation which I've commented on
many times where feminists idolize
masculinity they don't hate masculinity
know they put masculinity on a pedestal
they worship it so the idolized
masculinity but they hate masculine men
because it's sort of a competition they
want to take that masculinity and
appropriate it and have it for
themselves and guys like Kavanagh are
especially contemptible in their minds
because he's this is a successful man
who used to be apparently kind of a jock
and he liked the party and all that kind
of stuff so he's a regular kind of
masculine guy in that sense so he's the
exact prototype of the sort of man that
feminists hate because it's exactly the
sort of man they want to be that's they
paint him as this guy who's you know
aggressive obviously he's been
successful all these think that this
this is what this is how feminists think
women should behave so that's what you
have hatred for men and and the victim
mentality you see just how desperate
feminists are to be victims they'll take
any opportunity to be a victim I really
think feminists they if they could go
back in a time machine to the early 20th
century or before they would they would
do it in a heartbeat they would they
would love that they would love to live
in a situation where women really are
being persecuted where they really are
being disenfranchised they would love
that
if they actually had a real reason to be
victimized because that's that's what
they want more than anything in life but
they don't have
because women have all the same equal
rights in America as men they even have
more rights than men do and in many
respects so they're completely equal
they're not being persecuted at all not
even a little bit and they hate that
because they want it so badly and so
they go looking for persecution and they
say oh quit Cavanaugh's persecuting them
somehow or hey a guy is a guy is sitting
with his with his legs too wide on the
subway they're being persecuted or hey
you you interrupted me and so I'm being
personal I mean they're just looking for
any excuse
that's all that's coming out in this
from his Cavanagh thing but hopefully
the nightmare will be over soon for
Brett Kavanaugh and when that happens if
it happens as I said going back to the
beginning hopefully that'll be the end
of the story for him but that cannot be
the end of the story period because
there's a lot of following up that I
think some law-enforcement agencies need
to do so we can get to the bottom of all
this all right we'll see what happens
with the vote over the weekend and I'm
sure we'll talk about it on Monday have
a good weekend Godspeed